hey guys I'm Jess I'm Dan and it's
Tuesday so let's get started with some
gaming news first up if you've got a
Nintendo switch exciting things are
happening stay tuned for the next 40
seconds and we'll tell you what those
exciting things are the Nintendo switch
a shop is adding party game over cooked
special edition this week that game will
you chaotically prepare and serve meals
and I infuriate my co-workers by
preferring to jump to my death or just
play with a fire extinguisher instead of
washing dirty plates man I really need
to stop letting you write these for me
you sure dude an overcooked will arrive
on July 27 for $20 and the switch
version incorporates HD Rumble support
and includes the DLC for free in other
fun switch things today's patch from
minecraft on switch has upgraded the
resolution while docked to 1080p much to
the relief of fans who weren't so stoked
that it was going to run at 720p i've
docked and undocked microsoft explained
that the less than stellar resolution
was due to issues experienced shifting
from one resolution to the other but it
looks like they fixed those if you like
your video games a little flatter Rayman
legends definitive edition is coming to
switch on September 12 it'll include a
bunch of switch exclusive features that
take advantage of the console's controls
and touch screen and it'll also have
local wireless multiplayer between
switch systems in the company game
Ubisoft have also announced a free demo
he's going to arrive at some point in
this summer also there's a trailer man
that is so much switch news let's all
wear something else I don't know if
you've ever seen Jess play The Sims but
it is truly truly a sight to behold it's
honestly like watching a pro gamer play
I don't know dota or csgo it's it's it's
insane well soon I'll be min maxing my
Sims all over again when the sims 4
comes to Xbox one maybe no official
announcement has been made by Sims
publisher EA but a listing on the
Microsoft Store listed the game as
coming to Xbox one on November 17 The
Sims 4 recently came to origin access
the PC version of the subscription
service that lets you play a bunch of EA
games for the price of your monthly
subscription the game selection on
Origin access and EA access the Xbox
version are usually very similar so that
may be another hint well I'm appear as
two things the same sport isn't quite as
good as its predecessors it has a lot of
interesting systems going for it it's
very pretty and no matter which one of
them
I can promise you it will suddenly
before in the morning in real life as
you find yourself virtually
takingouttrash mouth simultaneously
ignoring your real life responsibilities
great game great game it's been about a
month since we've told you about the
free xbox games you can get with your
games with gold subscription let's
remedy that if you're an Xbox Live Gold
subscriber in August you'll get access
to slime rancher on August 1st and a
trials fusion on August 16th on Xbox one
spine rancher a first-person sim in
which you take care of adorable slime
creatures has been in early access on PC
for a while but August first marks its
official release date on Xbox one and
you can grab it for free if that sounds
too relaxing for you trials fusion is
the platformer with motorbikes that will
test your patience and skill it's also
home to a massive riddle that spanned
the globe and will not be solved until
2113 when one of four real-life keys
will unlock something in real life at
the eiffel tower seriously
on the xbox360 side you can grab the
fantastic Bayonetta from the 1st to the
15th and the destruction simulator Red
Faction
Armageddon from the 16th to the 31st you
can also grab grow up and Lego Pirates
of the Caribbean before the end of July
and Rundberg before August 5th tapes
that is everything we've got for you
today
do you remember to check back to games
for all the latest news and features
including our impressions of Uncharted
The Lost Legacy and if you haven't yet
make sure your subscribe so you don't
miss our smiling faces every day for you
for some gaming news we'll see you guys
tomorrow